et maria pacôme et notre invité ce soir
voilà alors est-ce que astrid est
contente
un street dix mois elle est contente
qu'un sourire à ce très content at il
rassuré on connaît la batterie si je
veux d'un str il est content de moi oui
comme dans l'allégresse ou bien alors
vous maria pacôme nombre d'anciennes
vous n'êtes pas comme est ce qu un
diable vous êtes là belle-mère foldingue
quoi voilà une fois de plus pourquoi
folle dingue non
fientes méchante mais pas folle dingue
ça vaut la peine c'est une méchante
femme agressive elle aime pas sa
belle-fille et l'alliance on peut même
son le petit bébé elle l'a dormait
méchamment elle dit à un moment oui bon
ça va
faut pas faire chier un carré aux
play-offs où elle est vraiment odieuse
heures juste un petit peu quand même là
la barre joue dans ce film soul est
moins que que vous l'avez été oui j'en
étais là slayer j'ai arrêté quand il
joue et c'est pour ça vous êtes devenu
auteur c'est parce qu'avant vous aviez
marre de faire ce à quoi le
voilà j'ai compris que les pièces que
vous écriviez t'es pas pire que celle
qu'on vous apportait c'était mieux
alors qu'ils avaient déjà il ya des
pièces bien meilleur mais ça part en
vrille et voilà et en plus vous avez
découvert que quand on touche les droits
d'auteur c'est plus sympa c'est surtout
ça qui était très belle a été très
agréable très très mais très mal à
marjah
mais qu'est ce qu'ils racontent comme
imbécillité là où bien sûr que non
j'aimerais beaucoup y avait de quoi vous
arrêter de travailler quand même dix
pensent à leurs noms mais j'y pense
alors on va on va piquer ton ton pognon
mais en fait ce qui est terrible et
maria pacôme et ça arrive souvent avec
les avec les grands acteurs c'est que
vous avez été bon j'ai fait une carrière
formidable vous avez réjouit nombre de
fois et en fait votre rêve secret
c'était de jouer tchekhov cette fameuse
cette fameuse phrase que vous adorez ne
me secouez pas comme ça je suis plein de
larmes
oui dites le moi comme vous l'auriez dit
mais ce n'est pas comme ça je suis plein
de larmes
ouais voilà ce qu'on a raté le cut maria
pacôme pendant la guerre votre père
était déporté à buchenwald et l'époque
vous êtes senti d'un seul coup très seul
trait libre et vous vous êtes dirigés
vers le vers le théâtre au cours simon
vous dites plutôt café d'à côté
d'ailleurs le phare oui oui n'ont jamais
été une femme d'aider des cours je crois
que je me suis faite toute seule comme
ça alors simon au cours simon vous a dit
t'es pas une beauté
mais entre garde dire quoi que vous
aviez une présence oui c'est ça ouais
alors
au revoir
je vois je vois c'est vraiment ces
moustiques je vois que tu es tombé sur
deux sur le même plan
je viens de te soutenir on s'était un
peu seul set va très bien donc oui toi
aussi un jeu te regarder à l'écran c'est
bon c'est bien mais à un moment donné
c'est pénible mais si avant le début de
l'émission ça va mais quand il va être
aussi valhalla matin voilà exactement
c'est que j'ai vu des trucs ordinaire
donc vouloir y raconte parce que les
prix n'ont pas vu j'ai vu monsieur de
gaulle donc l'amiral de gaulle croisé
gabriel cohn bendit a hole caves riel
cohn bendit lui a dit bonjour
gabriel cohn bendit il a tiqué le vieux
disque est drôle c'est que c'est des
rencontres par procuration ouais c'est
l'univers de cohn bendit avec le fils de
2 go oui voilà c'est ça qui est marrant
et lui la tique est en fait donc son
fish donna il a marqué le coup c'est
rigolo alors que maria pacôme est venu
au théâtre dans la guerre sans père
était déporté à buchenwald et qu'elle
allait au cours simon enfin plutôt à
côté du cours simon dans un district sa
belle le villars est alors s'ils ont
réellement c'est mieux en face d'accord
et simon lui a dit cette phrase
mémorable tu n'es pas une beauté nue
entre garde ce qui veut dire que tout de
suite il avait vu que vous aviez une
présence à la tête moi un peu pour me
flageller qui rajoute et n'est pas une
beauté regarde pas dû dire ça peut faire
mal c'est un peu excessif
il a dit ouah mais telle une présence
non
non y'a un moment fort et elle s'auto
flageller sa part en balade devrait même
pas déconner alors évidemment ce n'est
pas beaucoup d'argent à l'époque et
simon vous a dit toujours lui le cours
simon
tu peux pas payer mais tu as une gueule
je suis le sens il va dire tu n'es pas
une beauté n'a pas d'âge
donc ne sent pas une beauté tu vas pas
prévient le tueur est roi il avait je
crois qu'il avait confiance en moi
si vous voyez je travaillais pas
beaucoup il a dit tu restes alouettes et
vous êtes resté je suis parti c'est vrai
qu'à l'époque vous aviez pas beaucoup
d'argent vous étiez sous chamming's
continue d'ailleurs arrêté bien mais
c'est vrai qu'à 16 ans à 16 ans
seulement mariée à 16 ans vous étiez
apprenti chez un fabricant de chaussures
oui mais bien sûr j'étais sa harpe est à
ce moment-là wifag va travailler parce
que papa était dans la rue quand on
était tout jeune rémois et que fall et
25 du temps et c'est un peu dur mais
c'est dur trop plein de chat ouais et
c'est l'époque où maria pacôme mon cher
moustiques étaient donc mancka vous et
des photos publicitaires et à ce moment
là donc j'étais pas belle mais les
maillots de bain c'est l'époque on peut
le dire je crois ce soir parce que la
prescription
vous étiez un peu mal tourné à l'époque
non oui oui une présence j'étais le fait
que mon père était arrêtée on était des
mômes et que c'est un homme très sévère
le fait d'avoir cette liberté du jour au
lendemain et que dangereuse parce que
parce que d'abord j'étais très très bien
élevés mais très durement partir de là
voilà maintenant était un peu faible
voilà donc bien j'ai eu la chance c'est
la chance le théâtre le théâtre nous a
sauvés d'une vie dissolue maria pacôme
je sais mes rencontres ont sauvé
beaucoup prysmian entendre le théâtre nô
et puis voilà cette histoire de soutien
de famille a duré toute votre vie parce
que vous avez toujours été ensuite celle
qui a planté le fric à la maison voilà
oui
alors évidemment ça vous amener à
accepter des rôles qui était pas
obligatoirement ce que vous espériez
dans l'adolescence
vraiment pas vendre du tout de ce que
j'ai joué à jamais une chose honteuse
dans mais vraiment quand tu t'es
vraiment trop moche je disais non je
fais ben j'ai jamais et je n'étais pas
habité par le théâtre j'ai jamais eu 13
en jeu j'aimais bien j'aime bien écrire
je veux bien jouer
j'aime bien la vie surtout si tôt
j'avais gagné un que je gagnais fric les
jarres été très vite d'ailleurs et je
partais de la paillasse foutait le camp
je dépense mon fric et je reviens à mon
agent que j ai toujours mais tu feras
jamais de carrière et je m'en foutais
moi et j'avais là cette chance
extraordinaire de retrouver tout de
suite quelque chose à faire est ce que
vous pensez sérieusement maria pacôme
que vous avez eu la carrière que vous
méritiez à étant donné les marques comme
je le suis
les clients us et c'est vraiment c'est
incohérent la manière dont je vis c'est
une c'est une vraie chance un jeu mérite
pas cette carrière je méritais pas mieux
je regrette mes doigts moi je regrette
de ne pas avoir fait du cinéma mais
avoir été voir des metteurs en scène et
ça il faut le faire tes jours il faut se
déplacer
j'ai jamais rien fait tout ce qui m'est
arrivé c'est arrivé et je crois que j'ai
du talent c'est pour ça donc ayant des
qualités bon ben j'ai surnager maria
pacôme
en tout cas je sais pas si lui c'est
maria pacôme a été mariée avec maurice
ronet oui tu aimes le plus beau de tous
n'étant pas une beauté c'est une chance
j'ai pu avoir le plus belle des cinémas
et on était très amoureux avant l'été un
côté on était drôlement mignons tous les
deux étaient dingues de vous maurice
ronet vous imaginez le nombre des
rotations sont jalouses de vous ce soir
alors ce qui est très marrant c'est qu'à
l'époque jamais imaginé ça à l'époque
vous étiez avec maurice ronet vous étiez
un peu baba cool avant l'heure quoi vous
êtes parti dans le bouddhisme zen on a
fait des choses insensées qu'elle me
suis retrouvé à moustiers sainte marie
et ont trouvé là la vieille terre pour
refermer on a fait des choses dingues on
abandonner tout ce qui était théâtre
c'est fou c'est fou on n'était pas là on
était tout un groupe là il y avait des
gens même un peu qui après peintre tout
ça on est le théâtre était bien loin
on voulait une autre vie vous rêviez
d'une autre vie et moi j'ai commencé à
être un peu connu j'avais 33 2 l'an
encore un petit peu
avant de métier et ça m'était
complètement égal
j'avais envie de vous les faire des
choses c'est vrai que c'est terminé en
vendant de la lavande au bord des routes
en effet toute mignonne elle avec une
amie
on avait j'avais ma tâche et des
morceaux de 2,2 de tissus comme ça que
c'est tous des valeurs on éteignait
toutes les couleurs c'était très adroit
pour faire ça on l'a aidé à l'avant ne
tue pas mais du tout bronzé avec la les
deux jusqu'ici
et puis on arrêter les voitures ça fait
un fric fou avec ça on faisait des trucs
comme ça pour eux c'est mama cool avant
l'heure oui ouais alors michel est moins
souvent je compare michèle laroque à
elvire popesco parce qu'elles sont
roumaine toutes les deux mais je crois
que j'aurais pu aussi vous comparez à
maria pacôme temps qu'elle et michèle
laroque